good morning I just love that coat every
successful user is not just a number
it's a whole life a whole new story
thank you
Florian Fran show Brett and Oded for
sharing those remarkable stories with us
and thank you to each one of you for
building those apps and games that
impact so many lives and write so many
beautiful stories welcome to playtime
2017 beat an app that helps you
communicate better get healthier learn a
language or a game that provides pure
entertainment or an avenue for
self-expression or learning a new skill
your apps and games impact people who
are on 2 billion Android devices just
think about that for a moment amazing
isn't it and if you see the stories that
we just showed you you realize that the
connection between the app and the user
goes way beyond way beyond the technical
features that it provides we on Android
and play are humbled to provide a small
part of the technology to make those
connections possible in addition to
building great apps you have told us
that you want to support causes that
matter to you today I'm super excited to
announce the first of those initiatives
of supporting these causes we have
partnered with these developers to
support World Food Day a program that
Braille creates activism and brings
attention to people who are suffering
from hunger around the world throughout
this week we will promote these 11 apps
and games and hundred percent of the
proceeds of
key item in those apps and games will be
donated to the World Food Program give
these developers a big hand
I would also ask each one of you take
off your phones download these apps and
games play them right thank you for your
generosity in the coming months we look
forward to working with more of you to
find causes that matter to you and
support more things with bigger social
impact so here we are
playtime 2017 we were just talking about
it for years ago this was a tiny little
program in a small little room on the
Google campus and today you join a
global series of events with hundreds of
top developers across Berlin and some
Palo and Shenzhen and Singapore and
Seoul and Tokyo you know I can't even
keep track of the places that this is
happening and very bring top developers
together to learn what's latest at
Google as well as from each other so
what's the day going to look like we're
going to kick off by talking to you
about what's latest from Google in the
morning we also have ideal coming up
here
and talking to us about building apps
and games using immersive technologies
in the afternoon you will hear from each
other about best practices about
building great games driving engagement
launching successfully and keeping your
user happy throughout this day we are
going to have one theme that will come
up over and over again and that is about
sustainable engagement as you listen to
the tools that we are going to provide
you to engage your users I ask you to
think about this theme and ponder on a
few questions what a sustainable
engagement means for you in your app or
game are you seeing your users hitting
capacity what metrics are you using to
know what engagement is good and maybe
what isn't
how will we collectively build a happy
user base for a long time these are
important questions for all of us in the
industry because they have significant
impact on our businesses but also for
our responsibility towards our users and
these are difficult questions we hope to
continue the dialogue we start here
today to find answers for these
questions I speak for everyone on Google
Play when I say I'm super excited that
we have you all here today together at
the end of this day I hope you will tell
us that you heard something that excited
you and more importantly that you met
somebody who inspired you and with that
let's kick off playtime I'm gonna call
onstage we need to talk about Google
Play product vision
[Applause]
thanks Poornima hi I'm Bonita butch I am
responsible for the product team that
does the Play Store the Play console as
well as instant apps so Google has been
building mobile platforms for a while
obviously began with Android we've
expanded that now to cover everything
from washes to TVs to cars
plays the glue that binds these
platforms together it's what brings
these platforms to life by delivering
apps and games that our users want to
actually really get benefit of these
platforms and at the same time of course
helping you our developer partners build
meaningful sustainable businesses on on
these platforms so I'm going to walk you
through some of the big things we're
thinking about for the next year plus
and then the leads from different parts
of of play are gonna dive into details
so the course of the morning so we're
very proud of the success that we've had
in growing the store and growing the
developer ecosystem but with this growth
has that we definitely have faced some
challenges for the user the challenge is
that now there's two million plus apps
and games which one should they use
which one should they install download
play with and for you for our developers
how do you get to the users who actually
will care about your your app how do you
actually get them to engage more deeply
and to re-engage with an app they may
have on their phone but may not even
remember they have on their phone and if
you've invested in building an app or
game that really deeply pulls in the
user how do you get the benefit of that
in terms of attracting new users well
we've been thinking a lot about all of
these issues and and we've seen that the
for the store browse traffic that's
people who come to the store and come to
the homepage and say oh I'm bored show
me something that's really grown and so
how do we
helped solve some of these problems well
one thing is that we should really when
we in terms of our ranking in terms of
our personalization we should really
reward developers who've built apps and
games that are deeply engaging in the
past for Google we use this kind of data
but we've used things like click data
and install data but we haven't
until recently started using engagement
data in our ranking and now we are so
normalized across categories of course
we are leveraging things like well these
this app seems to engage users a lot
more should probably rank it higher
because it seemed like it it's it the
user users seem to like this more than
the norm for this category so using that
kind of data we invested a lot in
building our personalization in the
store really our mission is to for the
user to find a store that they feel is
really tailored to themselves that sort
of speaks to them we made big strides
not quite all the way there yet but
we've definitely when we look at our
metrics around this it's quite
impressive how much we've been able to
improve the the user believing that this
store is really tailored to them we're
also trying to do a number of things
around re engaging users with the apps
and games they already have Kara will
talk some more about this subsequently
to this but in a nutshell we've made new
destinations for games we've brought in
things like live event feeds into the
store and and in general were were as we
measure ourselves with new launches
we're thinking not just of new
high-quality installs but also helping
users rediscover something they already
may have on their phone um we we made a
big announcement around the general
availability to developers of Android
instant apps at i/o this this past May
well I'm very happy to say that the
store is now getting behind driving
traffic to instant apps in a very big
way
the first step this is an experiment
were we've launched recently in addition
to just being able to install an app
users will be able to try it with a
simple one-button press and that's as
though they already had the app and in
fact the example you see here is the
share the meal app that Poornima talked
about you know clearly you want to you
want to spread some joy you want to
share you want to share some benefit and
just click one button boom it's right
there it's no secret that large the
growth for the Android ecosystem is
happening in markets like India
Indonesia Brazil lots of users lots of
new users and also not surprising that
many of these new users encounter their
very first smartphone which may actually
be constrained in terms of memory
storage and maybe on a somewhat
bandwidth constrained network we are
launching android go a streamlined
version of android to be optimised for
these kind of devices and networks which
is rolling out in the next couple of
months we also are going to make the
store on in these markets leaner slimmer
etc and we're hoping to really present
apps and games in these markets that are
optimized for these conditions we have
for a while had the next guidelines for
building for for these kinds of devices
and users a number of developers already
adopted these we encourage you to take a
look at these if you haven't yet and see
how you can benefit from this this user
growth in the store we will for users in
on these devices in these markets be
prioritizing apps that are optimized for
them so so if for example you've built a
light app or if you slim down your app
we will be making sure the user gets to
see that as a high priority so in
closing I just want to say that through
the course of today this afternoon we'll
have will have product managers and
developer relations teams from across
different part
of Google available for one-on-one
sessions with you please take advantage
of this the agenda will explain who's
available when but definitely make sure
that you come with your questions with
your thoughts with your comments and if
you want to run ideas by us we're here
for you please take advantage of this
with that our last Matt Henderson who's
our lead for the play console to give
you some more details about that lots of
great stuff to share with you today so
two billion devices publishing software
to 2 billion devices it's a tremendous
opportunity but it's also challenging
and so it's important that we build
tools to help support your success play
can help you iterate on your app to get
it to high quality prior to release and
post release during the release process
we can help you to mitigate risks that
come up our tools can also help you to
understand business opportunities and
take advantage of those business
opportunities on the quality side
earlier this year at i/o we announced
android vitals in the play console
android vitals is a program to help you
build apps and games of high quality how
important is quality will 50% of 1 star
rated reviews on Play mention app
stability and bugs so if you want to
avoid one-star rating reviews this is a
great thing to invest Timon we're really
excited that just since IO Android
vitals has really been embraced so
already 65% of top developers are using
android vitals to help learn how they
can improve their app quality vitals
helps you understand three areas of bad
user experience across stability battery
and rendering from today five new
metrics are launching in vitals to help
you understand problems more deeply
for app stability vitals now reports
when the same user session is affected
by multiple NRS and crashes these
repeated problems cause user frustration
leading to risk of an install for
battery vitals now highlights when
excessive activity takes place in the
background leading to unnecessary
battery drain for example we now report
excessive life lie scans an excessive
network usage in the background as well
as stuck way clocks until now Android
vitals has generated metrics from users
on the nexus and pixel devices today our
coverage expands dramatically it's up 25
fold from just earlier in the year it's
a huge increase and includes a spectrum
of flagship devices and mid-range
devices as well we've also revamped the
Android vital section in the Play
console with a richer user experience
there's an overview for metrics at a
glance there's time series charts
there's also benchmarks so you can
compare your own metrics against the
metrics of other developers as a whole
and as you improve your app quality we
want to make sure that end-users find
those great experiences
that's why Android vitals are now a key
signal for Google Play and a number of
user facing areas our search and
discovery algorithms take vitals into
account when they favor apps with better
vitals and vitals are an important
signal when your app is being considered
for promotional opportunities like the
new and updated collection editors
choice collection the Google Play Awards
and the recently launched Android
excellence program the pre-launch report
is a way to improve quality before the
apps published it automatically crawls
and tests your apks on a variety of
different devices looking for crashes in
security vulnerabilities and what we've
observed is 90% of the time that the
pre-launch report testing robot
discovers crashes in an app the
developer chooses not to take that app
forward into production it's modified
before going into production so this is
really working well identifying problems
that are then fixed before going out to
real users from today every apk that's
submitted to alpha and beta track is
going to get a pre-launch report so this
is dramatically expanding the
availability of the program we're also
launching a new robot tester that
reaches deeper into the app and
discovers more crashes more problems
we're adding new performance metrics as
well to the pre-launch report covering
CPU memory Network and rendering app
security is another key part of a
quality user experience and plays
security team scenes security
recommendations to thousands of
developers to help fix vulnerabilities
today we're further investing in
security with the Google Play security
reward program here's how it works to
start with we'll be inviting developers
of popular apps to opt into the program
participating security researches will
try to find vulnerabilities in those
eligible apps they submit the
vulnerabilities in a report via your bug
reporting process and our partner hacker
one can set up a free reporting process
if you don't already have one
once the vulnerability is fixed the
researcher reports it to the Play Store
and the security reward program will
generate a reward a payout from Google
to that researcher Google's security
team will then scan all apps for that
vulnerability and send security
recommendations to any other affected
developers some of Google's security
team and some of the hacker one team
here today
so if you want to learn more chat
further with them I encourage you to do
so so tools in the play console can also
help you mitigate risks when you're
targeting and releasing your app to your
audience alpha and beta testing is being
one of the features at play
that developers really love most more
than 300-thousand developers use alpha
and beta tracks we've got some new
capability that we're adding to that
country targeting at the track level so
until today country targeting was fixed
across all track States but now you can
bait a test in specific countries so you
can bait a test in country a before
launching in that country publicly even
though your app may be fully launched in
country B in the coming weeks we're
going to be also launching country
targeting in staged rollouts so for a
new release of an existing app you may
use staged rollouts to increase that
release to specific percentages of
production users and with country
targeting you'll be able to control
which countries that process is
happening to over time the device
catalog was also a new feature we
announced at i/o this year and it's been
tremendously popular so this is a tool
where you can search devices by
attributes like RAM system-on-chip
screen size and more it shows you your
apps performance for specific devices
and you can set targeting rules if you
want to exclude some devices if they're
not suitable for your app we're now
launching a new feature that allows you
to save device search queries so if you
have a combination of filter settings
that have perhaps gets you large screen
devices that are running Android oh and
meet a certain bar for RAM size then you
can save that as a custom query and use
it again in the future and more more
quickly navigate to it in the future
another cool feature we're adding here
is based off questions that we received
from developers often which is why isn't
this specific device supported by my app
so in the device catalog we're launching
today a feature where we answer that
exact question you can pick a specific
device in the device catalog and it will
tell you reasons why your app doesn't
support that device for example on on
the screen here the production apk
requires accelerometer feature and that
beta apk requires the camera autofocus
feature which this device doesn't
support so you can go into device
catalog and find those sorts of reasons
to help you understand what's going on
we continue to add features to the Play
console to help you grow your business
and subscriptions are the fastest
growing developer business model we have
new features to help with that so easier
setup means you can launch your
subscription app faster we recently
announced the official release of the
Play billing library and this simplifies
the development process for Google Play
billing by making sure that you're
always using the latest in app billing
features we're making it easier for you
to test your payment flows by providing
a good form of payment and a bad form of
payment for each license test account so
you can test without having to use a
real payment method we're also updating
the subscription settings in the Play
console so you can configure your
subscription SKUs and an app level now
your business can't survive if you don't
get users our research has shown that
78% of subscribers start with a free
experience so we're introducing
improvements to our free trial logic to
make it smarter in order to reduce free
trial abuse we're now enforcing the
user's 1 free trial at the app level and
you can manage that setting in the new
subscription setting page on on the Play
console this setting is available today
and enforcement
gonna start in December this year we've
heard feedback from developers that some
of you would like to have shorter free
trial lengths so now the minimum free
trial lengths will be three days for
those of you with content costs this
lowers the marginal cost of acquisition
while acquiring users is important you
can't stay in business long if you don't
keep them I owe we talked about a new
feature called account hold and I'm
pleased to announce that it's now open
for general availability and can be
implemented by checking the account
whole box in the subscriptions setting
and play console we're also launching a
new wind back features so starting today
we're going to notify you immediately
when a subscriber state change including
cancellation so no more waiting until
the end of the month to check the API
and find out that a subscriber cancelled
2 weeks ago
instead you can understand immediately
and and trigger a communication to the
user especially if there's something
something new that may entice them to
retain the subscription maybe they
didn't know about a new feature maybe
they didn't know about a new show that
you had just launched and so these wind
back features we think can help you to
increase user retention also starting
today we're giving users the ability to
restore a subscription that hasn't
completely subscribed it hasn't
completely expires so they had a
subscription they unsubscribed but they
have the ability to restore that with
without going through this the whole
subscription creation funnel again and
we think that's going to remove some of
the friction for them to get started and
remain in in the relationship in the app
you can opt into that subscription
restoration setting through the new
subscription settings in the play
console as well so lots of stuff we hope
their new features help as you continue
to build amazing apps and games and Kara
is now going to share some news about
the Play Store
Thanks before I get started I first of
all wanted to say a big thank you to all
of you for the very very hard work you
do in day-in day-out in creating really
great user experiences it makes my job
easier but most importantly it really
enables us to really deliver great
content that creates user experiences
across our users so today I'm going to
talk about some changes with me on the
Play Store to really make it easier for
users to discover and to engage with our
great content so as vineet mentioned
plays mission is to bring devices to
life on mobile and beyond whether for
your phone watch or even your car play
is a thread that connects two billion
devices to content that makes them truly
magical now personalization here is the
building block that's made even more
powerful by having great content to
recommend and great surfaces for those
recommendations I want to share with you
some of the way that we've improved
recommendations sorry improved our
personalization over the last year as
well as walk through some of the ways
that we're creating new experiences to
give users a much better way to engage
with the content in the Play Store so a
lot of the magic of plays
recommendations happens behind the
scenes so I want to pull back the
curtain a little and give you some
insight into how we match that great
can't the right content to the right
user to help users explore we've built a
taxonomy that really creates thousands
and thousands of topics that enables a
user to go much deeper into content and
also gives the user more control we've
used this as you'll see here in the
recently launched
refinements where a user can make
choices in delving down into the content
that's of interest to them we've also
used these to power really great
recommendations across our home pages
we've also improved our ranking to make
it more contextually relevant and also
much fresher so for example for a
football fan here on the right we know
that that person is interested in
football and so we surface this content
much more prominently in the store given
that users interests as well as the fact
that it's a trending topic across all
our efforts as you heard from both
Panama and vineet we really are thinking
about ongoing engagement and re
engagement and so you'll see here don't
forget to try which surfaces apps that a
user has recently installed so within
our recommendations we want to also help
users to decide what to install there's
so many things but what should they
really install so we want to highlight
the best of the catalog so we've always
had editorial curation at play but it's
not always being clear to user what's
editorial versus other recommendations
and why we're highlighting it to them so
a major focus of this year has been on
creating new editorial experiences
including rich long-form content as
you'll see here which shows two users
the reasons why we love this three great
reasons why we think this is a great
Apple game a user should engage with
this editor's choice is now live in 17
countries around the world and in future
we'll be integrating this not just in
its own section but it will be
integrated in other parts of the Play
Store to really help users throughout
their discovery experience so a large
part of editorial is play having an
opinion of
what's best for users and so we'll be
using these richer content experiences
to highlight the best content that we
have in our events such as best of play
we really want to be able to recognize
and reward you as developers who create
this great content and there is a spot
here coming up later this year where
you'll see our best of Play 2017 so we
also want to recognize those that take
full advantage of the Android platform
through programs like Android excellence
which you'll see here on the right you
know this will be refreshed each quarter
and you can reach out to your beedi team
for any further information so we know
how important games are to our users and
I want to share several changes we're
making on the Play Store to really
create a much more engaging browse
experience one that really does bring
users back continually to the store to
engage and re-engage with our great
content so let's start with navigation
now I know it's very obvious but games
are different from apps and so we're
reflecting that in elevating games to
its own destination now we do hope that
that and expect that that will help
drive more users into games
to discover that great content but it
also provides an excellent foundation
for creating experiences that are really
unique to games such as immersive
recommendations that highlight videos
screenshots of actual gameplay we also
want to give users more control over how
they browse that games experience so an
example here is we've created a premium
section within games that highlights
paid paid games and this launched it
launched last month
this is also great for showcasing games
on sale using the news strike through
price feature that really enables a user
to see the value that you're delivering
to date given this has launched a month
we're seeing really great engagement
where users are going much further and
deeper into the content and really
engaging with many more of our premium
games newness is really important to our
gamers and so this is a topic that we're
approaching in a few different ways
similarly to premium games we're
creating we're experimenting with a new
section on new games so this highlights
some of our best new games across our
popular franchises as well as our
amazing Indies
we're also exposing pre-registration in
many more places through the store as
well as much more prominently so we do
hope that this will give users a sense
of what's coming up soon and enable you
as developers to build momentum behind a
new game launch you'll see here also
that another example of an experiment
that were that we're doing is
experimenting with pre-registration
rewards and this is shown on the store
listing page for the example of our
Angry Birds match again we look out for
more of these things in that are coming
up in the next few months and into 2018
and finally we are also making out top
charts more responsive so we'll be
updating them multiple times each day to
ensure that we really are bringing
freshness and newness to the store but
there's Panama and banette both touched
on the store really does need to do much
more than just help users find a new
game or app to install we really want to
create and are working to create a
destination
for users to find out what's happening
in the games that they already play so
here you'll see we've started
highlighting major in-game events
through store feed tree and these have
had a great reaction from users who are
really engaging and re engaging as well
as producing great results for
developers so you'll start to see many
more live ops through the store in
different parts of the store coming up
and into 2018
you'll see an example of this is the
live ops card on games home which
highlights exciting events happening in
the games that a user is playing or has
installed and this encourages that user
to really get back into the content and
and really make sure that they don't
miss out and lastly we also want to make
sure through don't forget to play that
we're creating every opportunity to
recommend and ensure users are engaging
with the content that they're interested
in so that was a lot on games but what
about apps we're also looking to drive
ongoing engagement with apps by really
ensuring that users can get the most out
of the apps that they already have
starting with entertainment we're taking
a much more content forward approach
which you can expect to see more of
across other categories in future so
here's an example of what we mean in
practice so we're able to use the
information about the content in each
app to power a better search experience
so in this case a user is interested in
Game of Thrones now while that user
might be looking for an app or a game
related to Game of Thrones we know that
they're probably looking to watch the
show so in this case we can surface the
HBO going up and the HBO now app
make it clear to users that they can
stream and watch Game of Thrones through
both of those apps we've also started to
highlight major in-app content moments
through store featuring and we're
experimenting with other dedicated
services through the store to surface
these content moments so this is an
example here working in partnership with
HBO now to surface many of the different
shows where we make it clear to users
that you can either you can either
subscribe to the app or you can purchase
the episodes so again giving users
multiple ways to engage with the content
that they're interested in so it's
vineet said continuing with the theme
about the storm it being about more than
just installs we're really excited to
announce the first integration with
android instant apps within the Play
Store you can see here the try Now
button which really encourages users to
jump right into the content this
addresses users immediately right in the
moment we will be experimenting with
different ways to surface this to users
so expect more to see expect to see more
on this next year so that was quite a
lot but I'm really excited about the new
experiences that we're creating and the
new content types that we're developing
you know this gives new ways this gives
users new ways to explore the catalog
and gives them lots more reasons to come
back to the store and continue to
explore the store along the theme of
continued engagement ongoing engagement
and obviously re-engagement expect to
see a lot more on that in 2018 so now
over to share here
who's going to talk about crow hi
everyone my name's ID I'm a product
manager on the Chrome OS team before I
jump into what we're going to talk a
little bit about today can I just ask
how many of you are familiar with Chrome
OS maybe used it how many of you have a
Chromebook okay awesome so thank you for
using it trying it we're very excited to
be here at play time and what we wanted
to do is share with you a little bit of
an introduction to Chrome OS and how
apps can work on that platform so for
those of you who may be a little less
familiar let me maybe start with some of
the basics so Chrome OS since we started
building a product has been about these
three things speed simplicity and
security we want Chrome OS to be a fast
operating system fast to start fast to
use we want it to be simple easy to use
that we think of Chrome OS like a tool
that just disappears and lets you as a
user get on with whatever you were there
to do and we want it to be secure that's
been core to the way we've built Chrome
OS ever since we first started so that
idea of that set of ideas which has been
very constant has led us to some success
so Chromebooks shipments overtook Macs
in the United States last year and for
those of you who are familiar with
Chrome OS are very strong in the
education space so Chromebooks actually
outsell every other device combined in
education but it's not only in that
education space where we're growing and
getting stronger we've seen nearly 20%
Urania growth in retail and we'll be
continuing to invest in the success of
Chromebooks
across the company the end of this year
and over the next few years so the
Chrome OS team is new here at play time
because the Play Store is fairly new to
Chrome OS so last year at i/o we
announced the availability of Google
Play on Chrome OS and we've been working
working hard to improve how play and
Android apps will work on Chrome OS so
just a couple weeks ago we worked with
our colleagues in the Google Hardware
team on the launch of the new Google
pixel book and the pixel book is really
a sort of next step in the evolution of
the Play Store on Chrome OS and we feel
the quality of the experience and the
quality of the apps that are running on
it it's good but it's not just Chrome OS
when we think about Android apps running
on the desktop Chrome OS is is what we
do but also we work very closely with
teams like the Samsung team who have Dex
built into that product so expecting to
see more and more of that desktop
projection activity running on mobile
and that is very very similar
essentially Android apps running inside
a desktop environment so that's some of
the reasons why we think this is
important for developers the types of
apps though can be different so for me
personally when I use apps on my mobile
phone I tend to use it in short bursts
and when I pay for apps on mobile I tend
to spend just a few dollars but on
desktop the kinds of apps that I'll use
I will use hours at a time often many
hours at a time and I'm happy to spend
up to a few hundred dollars because
often the usage is professional in
nature so these really simple changes in
the form factor we're going to a bigger
screen getting faster inputs with mouse
and keyboard drive a different kind of
usage and that's been reflected in our
analytics when we look at how people are
using apps on these two platforms so
immersive apps like Skype Sin City
AutoCAD 360 our analytics tell us that
users spend more time in that app on a
Chromebook than they do on a smartphone
because the type of usage can be
different so now that we've talked a
little bit about the Y what I'd like to
do is share with you briefly some
thoughts on how you can help optimize
your apps so it runs really well inside
Android inside a desktop operating
system like Chrome OS
so first of all Chromebooks work like
any other Android device if you have an
app in the Google Play Store it probably
already works on Chrome OS and for those
of you who have Chrome OS devices I hope
you've had a chance to go into the Play
Store on those devices and check out
your apps running there already
many developers understandably focus
their testing on mobile devices so once
you see it running on a big screen on a
laptop form-factor often the need for
optimization becomes immediately
apparent so the best piece of advice I
could share there is just try it that
said we've worked with many many of you
and many other developers to do those
optimizations and we found that some of
the questions come down to these four
differences between mobile and desktop
first one of those is wider screens and
it's probably the most common issue so
some apps don't use real estate like
they should on a wider screen so this is
stuff that we need to do - this is an
older version of Google Maps a new
version fixes this problem so as you can
see the content is sort of locked in
this column in the middle of the screen
and there's all of this space on the the
sides of the screen that isn't really
being used and here's another example is
the conversation from Google Hangouts so
in this example if it's on mobile
everything flows kind of neatly down the
middle of the screen and as you read
down the conversation you can go from
bold a bubble but in the case of a wider
screen the two sides of the conversation
or hard pan left and right so that I
have to scan from one side to the other
to the other to the other and it makes
it a little bit awkward and this is
exactly the kind of thing that just
becomes immediately apparent once you
see it running on a larger screen the
second note is that phones are default
portrait while laptops the default
landscape so this is an example this is
a game called a storm for rise of Balor
and it's built for portrait Chrome OS
respects that setting so you're not at
your laptop and looking at it like this
so we do orient in the correct direction
but this is a case where it's a rich a
graphics rich game you have all this
beautiful content in the middle of
screen but these black bars on the side
of it now we know that fixing this kind
of thing is non-trivial but we wanted to
share another example we've worked with
this team this is the bubble Witch Saga
3-game so this is a game where the
action is happening in a vertical space
those of you who played this game so to
shoot these balls up to catch balls at
the top of the same color and the
actions happening in that vertical strip
so what would you put on the sides so
this is an example of how this team has
worked with our team to find a good
solution for making sure that that sort
of graphical richness it's spread a
little bit towards the sides of the
screen the third thing is different is
windowing
so Chrome OS like most desktop operating
systems has a windowing system because
multitasking is part of the benefit of
doing that now many apps assume that the
window size equals the display size
which makes complete sense on a regular
mobile Android device but that's not
always the case even sometimes on
Android wear you can do sort of split
screen controls on sort of newer Android
releases but part of the value of
desktop is multitasking and in this case
the window size probably doesn't equal
the display size so apps need to
understand that so when an input is
coming into the app if the input is
being read with respect to the display
size and the output is being pushed out
with respect to the apps position that
can create input offset errors so that's
just an example of some of the kinds of
things to watch out for because of the
windowing system so just being careful
to to read and ensure that input and
output are being coordinated with the
with respect to the same artifacts that
will help eliminate those kinds of
errors so finally a keyboard pointer and
stylus input which on desktop machines
enables a user to be able to input
information much much faster there's
lots of common States here that are kind
of uncommon on mobile so for example
hover States I see your tooltip within
an app it's an sorry I see an icon
within an app and I want to know what
that does I can hover over it and get a
tooltip on desktop which helps me
understand what it does before I have to
click on him
so obviously that's just kind of an
uncommon interaction another example is
swiping to dismiss that's really common
on mobile and very natural so your an
email app or a reminder that for example
and I swipe away to dismiss on desktop
that's kind of weird because you have to
select it and drag it to the side with a
mouse or a touchpad so understanding how
the usage patterns change as you go from
one form factor to another will help
developers build an app will help you
build an app that works in both of these
cases and those updates can be really
simple so this is flack when we worked
closely with the slack team on ensuring
that app works really well on Chrome OS
so if you're in slack and you want to
send a message originally before we went
down the path of working with them you
would enter a message inside the app
running on Chrome OS and hit enter here
and it would give you a carriage return
so simple change hitting enter here now
sends the message it just helps that app
behave a little bit more like what you
would expect a desktop app to do and
lots of simple changes can add up to a
much better user experience so as I
mentioned and you've seen a couple of
examples many we've been working with
many app developers to implement these
couple I wanted to highlight so on the
left here is squid so this is a
note-taking app and a drawing app they
are taking advantage of an additional
new API that we've built into Chrome OS
super low latency
down to just 10 milliseconds that's
where you can get down to and that makes
writing and drawing feel much more
natural so many many apps in the Play
Store who can take advantage of this and
stylus inputs are working with us on
ensuring that they can take advantage of
this super low latency but also adding
keyboard controls to games like in this
case Star Wars Galaxies of Heroes so
that users can feel a little more
immersed in the action when they're
running this on desktop those are just a
couple there are many many more teams
that we've been working with for those
of you who are here from those teams
thank you we hope to work with you more
and and for those of you who we haven't
talked to yet we'll look forward to
talking with you a little bit more so
ongoing we want to do whatever we can to
highlight great apps that work on Chrome
OS we did this at the launch of the
pixel book or we highlighted a number of
apps and demos to press etc but there's
lots more that we want to do we want to
show people the best of the apps that
are available in play on Chrome OS
features on play in store demos websites
press review kits free loads and much
much more so we would love for you to
come and chat with us in the classroom
at 2:00 p.m.
we'd love to work as many of you that we
are working with more we'd love to work
as many of you who we aren't yet so
please go and chat to us at 2 p.m. and
well we'd love to discuss with you some
more so with that I'd like to hand you
over to Nathan p.m. on our developer
platform to daydream thank you I'm
Nathan it's a awesome to be here and I
think it's safe to say that over the
last decade phones have become
dramatically more powerful right the
phones that we have today have bigger
higher resolution screens faster CPUs
and GPUs more memory and storage than
they had a decade ago but one thing that
hasn't changed very much at all is the
sensors on the devices themselves right
we have GPS cameras accelerometers too
we had those a decade ago and if you
think about it these sensors are
fundamentally how the phone understands
its place in the world and because they
haven't changed a lot I'm excited to
talk about how they're about to change
and what we're calling augmented reality
and if you're not familiar with it all
going to reality is basically a
synthesis of advancements in computer
vision with these incredibly powerful
computing platforms we all carry around
in our pockets and what augmented
reality does is it allows the phone to
synthesize information around about the
world and actually compute the precise
position and orientation of that device
understand the world around it and allow
you the developer to actually integrate
digital information in the context of
real world objects which is exactly
where it's the most accessible and
useful and augmented reality is going to
let us do incredible new things on our
phones for example you can shop for
furniture without ever leaving your home
you can browse the world's largest
warehouse of couches you can pick one
that you want place it in your room and
see it in exactly the right scale and
exactly the right proportions lit by the
real light from the real window in the
real world because augmented reality
allows to understand the objects in the
world we can actually learn about them
and interact with them through augmented
reality so you can finally actually make
a good cup of coffee on that office
espresso machine that you've always
wondered about of course augmented
reality is going to be great for gaming
and communication oddly the reality will
allow us to play have fun express our
personalities in totally new world in
totally new ways and blur the difference
between our digital selves and our real
selves and of course because augmented
reality allows the phone to understand
the world in so much greater precision
it's going to allow us to navigate the
world indoors and out in ways that have
never been possible before of course
this is something we have actually a lot
of experience with at Google we've been
doing
ar since 2014 through what was called
project tango and if you're not familiar
with it tango was a hardware program
that enhanced certain phones with new a
are specific sensors and through tango
we learned an incredible amount about
like what it takes to run and create
compelling smartphone our experiences on
Android the challenge for us though of
course is that as you can imagine this
requirement of a custom sensor suite
limited the rate that we could scale the
tango specific ecosystem and one things
that we're of course most proud about at
Google is that today Android is the
world's most popular mobile computing
platform with over 2 billion users and
so what I want to talk to you about
today is how we're bringing augmented
reality to the world at Android scale
it's a brand new technology just
released a couple months ago called AR
core and essentially what AR core is
it's an adaptation of the core
innovations and algorithms from tango
but all implemented in software so they
can run on commodity Android phones
without any modification whatsoever and
as a developer a our core is going to
give you three powerful foundational
technologies the first of which is
called motion tracking and this is what
actually computes the position and
orientation of the phone and updates it
over time so you can place a virtual
object look at it walk around it get
closer and move back and have that
object feel like it's actually stationed
in the real world just like the
Scarecrow on the screen but of course in
order to place you know that virtual
object you need to understand the
geometry of the world so we have a
second technology called environmental
understanding and what environmental
understanding does is it looks at the 3d
structure of the world and synthesizes
that for you into identifying major
features like the plane of the ground or
this stage lastly though we won't
understand not just the atoms of the
world but the photons of the world as
well we won't understand the
illumination of our scenes so that you
can actually capture the ambient
lighting apply it to digital objects as
they feel married into the scene and it
can even react to changes in
illumination like our friend
hardly lyin here on the video so aircore
works on qualified devices running
Android N and and above
today we're in what's called a Developer
Preview so we've limited AR core to
specific phones that's the pixel pixel
to pixel XL and pixel to XL and the
Samsung Galaxy s8 but we're going to be
exiting the Developer Preview very soon
and when we do later this winter AR core
is going to run on a hundred million
Android devices and we're partnering
with the entire Android ecosystem to
scale that number aggressively next year
and beyond which is an incredible amount
of scale for a brand new technology so
if you're a developer of course you want
to use this stuff and actually get
started so we have great SDKs for
Android studio unity and unreal these
are native easy to use high-performance
api's so whether you're a game developer
or a native app developer you can
actually get started building for AR
core today of course at Google we care a
lot about the web it's deep in our DNA
and we believe that ultimately the web
is going to be part of bringing AR to
everyone and so we're investing actually
in web a our standards and brought
prototype browsers that allow web
developers to eventually have the same
capabilities as all of you native app
developers have today one thing I want
to bring up it's really important I all
of you are here because you've built
amazing apps and great businesses on top
of them and I'm sure you hear about a
new technology especially something
involves 3d like AR you're thinking you
know do I have to like start from
scratch so I have to build a brand new
app to take advantage of AR and I'm very
happy to say that Noah you actually
don't have to do that one of the things
that's amazing about and great about AR
and has been a design criteria for our
AR SDKs is that we want to make sure
that you can actually add AR as an
enhancement to the apps that you've
already built and have users engaging
with so of course for some of you you
may see AR as an opportunity to start a
brand new business a brand new kind of
app
but for the rest of you you can create a
are like a new feature like a new
capability added to your app and if
that's if your you need a developer user
you need the SDK native and Android
studio we've got you covered
and unreal as well so for all of you you
can add augmented reality to your
existing app exactly where it matters
most and then when it's when you ready
to something else move on to a different
capability or part of your user flow you
know I'm personally incredibly excited
about this new technology how it's gonna
allow our phones to understand the world
the way it's gonna let us as developers
integrate and enhance our understanding
of the user in the world with our
display of it but if you're still a
little bit skeptical we've got a fun
video that hopefully convinces you that
this is pretty awesome
so let's roll the video
[Music]
[Applause]
well thanks there if you're interested
in building for a Ark or please check
out developers.google.com slash AR it's
got links to documentation getting
started downloads for our SDKs a ton
more or of course you're here come check
out our classroom on VR and AR later
this afternoon just across the hall
thank you all so much for your time
we're going to take a quick 10-minute
break and we'll see you back here
afterwards thank you so much
you